IRCC and Immigration Minister Mark Miller
Mayage statement announced
unfortunately
study
permit holder
to see April 30th at a full time come currently allowed
again 3rd interchange I or whatever.
Study permit applications Legion only application
Lagania under Student Partnership Programs.
So did it GIC
the requirement on the Sopella GIC requirement 10,000.
So within the main changes in September,
that disheartening change
a year 2,024th.
I personally know
so many people generally work public expired.
Unfortunately,
IRCC has made their stand very clear
that they are not going to extend
this 18 months extension policy anymore.
So please figure out your stuff. Thank you.